- [Voiceover] Paige!
- [Voiceover] What?
- [Voiceover] I think
we left something out
of the last video.
- [Voiceover] Oh no.
- [Voiceover] I left exclamations
out of the last video!
- [Voiceover] That's not good.
- [Voiceover] Okay, we can fix this.
- [Voiceover] Okay.
- [Voiceover] We just
need to make a video.
- [Voiceover] Yes.
- [Voiceover] Oh, hello grammarians.
Hello Paige.
- [Voiceover] Hi David.
- [Voiceover] So, I want to talk today
about the exclamation!
- [Voiceover] Whoa.
- [Voiceover] An exclamation
is a type of sentence,
so previously we covered
three other kinds of sentence.
- [Voiceover] Mm-hmm.
- [Voiceover] We covered
declarative sentences,
which are just sort of statements, right.
We covered interrogative
sentences, which are questions.
And we covered imperative
sentences, which are orders.
- [Voiceover] Mm-hmm.
- [Voiceover] But, but I forgot
to include the exclamation!
I didn't actually forget, I
just wanted to save space.
- [Voiceover] Oh okay.
- [Voiceover] But Paige,
what is an exclamation?
- [Voiceover] So it's a sentence
or maybe a word that's like
an expression of a really strong emotion.
That's why we were
screaming a lot and stuff.
Those were all exclamations.
- [Voiceover] So it
doesn't even necessarily
have to be a sentence,
you said, so it could
just be something like, ow!
- [Voiceover] Right.
- [Voiceover] Like an
interjection like that.
- [Voiceover] Yeah,
that's a great example.
If you hurt yourself,
you might scream, ow!
That's an exclamation.
- [Voiceover] Can an exclamation also be
an imperative, like if I said, look out!
- [Voiceover] Yeah, I think
so, right, that's an order.
- [Voiceover] Yeah.
- [Voiceover] And it's being,
it's being exclaimed, it's being yelled.
So I think that's an exclamation too.
- [Voiceover] Mm-hmm.
- [Voiceover] So there's some overlap
with like imperative and
exclamation sometimes.
- [Voiceover] Mm-hmm, I
would also say that there's
probably an overlap with
declarative sentences too.
- [Voiceover] That's
true, that's very true.
- [Voiceover] So you could be like, ah,
that ogre is about to attack the village!
- [Voiceover] Right,
that is just a statement,
but you're clearly pretty scared about it.
So there's an exclamation point.
- [Voiceover] But I could
also walk that statement back
also as an exclamation and say,
I was wrong about the ogre, he's nice!
- [Voiceover] Oh, he was
just coming to say hi.
- [Voiceover] He's just coming to say hi.
- [Voiceover] Right.
- [Voiceover] Give you
a big ol' thumbs up.
So we're expressing something.
We're expressing strong emotion.
We could just be very
excited about something.
- [Voiceover] Right.
- [Voiceover] Or you can
use exclamation points
when you're trying to convey
that someone is speaking at high volume.
- [Voiceover] Okay, right.
- [Voiceover] So I
could be yelling across,
you know, the field, to you, my pal.
- [Voiceover] Mm-hmm.
- [Voiceover] To be like,
don't worry about the ogre!
He's just bringing snacks.
- [Voiceover] Okay, so
there's not even necessarily
strong emotion there, you
just want me to hear you.
- [Voiceover] Mm-hmm.
- [Voiceover] 'Cause I'm far away.
- [Voiceover] So Paige, I reckon that's,
that's what an exclamation is.
- [Voiceover] I think so.
- [Voiceover] Expression of
strong emotion or volume,
so they can be, they're
not always sentences,
so they can be interjections like, ow!
Or they can be full
sentences like, look out!
Or that ogre is about
to attack the village!
- [Voiceover] Yeah, it
can be a lot of things.
- [Voiceover] Be a lot of things.
Just like you can learn
anything, David out.
- [Voiceover] Paige out.